- If your vision is not
routinely called crazy,
then perhaps your vision isn't big enough,
and disruptive enough?
Are you being busy, being busy?
Have you lost that connection
to the life you wanted to live
when you were a little kid?
You can be a history maker,
or you can be liked by
everyone around you,
you can't be both.
- Hello, Believe Nation, it's Evan,
my one word is believe
and I believe in people more
than they believe in themselves.
And my sincere hope is
that if you see in yourself
what I see in you, you'll be
able to change the planet.
So to help you on your journey,
today we're going to learn
from best-selling author
and leadership speaker, Robin Sharma
and my take on his Top 10
Rules of Success, Volume Two.
Rule number two is my personal favorite,
and I'd love to know which
one you guys like the best.
Also as you're watching,
if you here something that
really resonates with you,
please leave it down in the comments below
and put quotes around it so other people
can be inspired by it as well.
And if you leave it within
the first couple hours
of this video going live,
you have a chance to win
one of two daily prizes.
(swooshing)
(booming)
(upbeat instrumental music)
(swooshing)
- Every genius entrepreneur
has an eccentric vision.
So, they're posibilitarians.
They are the people who said,
"You know," (breathes deeply)
"well, here's the way the
industry has always been,
"and here's the way the status quo is,
"but here's what we're going to do."
What's coming to the top
of my mind right now,
as I record this, is Uber.
So you've got Travis
Kalanick, and literally,
through that single app, I
mean, they don't own any taxis,
they don't own any cars, they don't really
have any inventory.
But through that single
app, Uber disrupted
the entire industry of that
level of transportation.
And so, these people,
these genius entrepreneurs,
come up with a ridiculously
disruptive idea,
that is absolutely
eccentric in its vision.
And that's why people call them crazy.
And I'll simply say to
you, if you're vision
is not routinely called crazy,
then perhaps your vision
isn't big enough, and disruptive enough.
And we change the world,
when we change the game.
And Bono is sharing this
story, that I believe he heard,
and it was the person walks
inside Kanye West's living room,
surveys the living
room, and cannot believe
what's on one wall of Kanye
West's (chuckles) living room.
And it's this giant poster of Kanye West.
And so the person who is
in the living room goes,
"Kanye, it's a beautiful living
room, but why do you have
"this massive poster of yourself
in your own living room?"
And Kanye replies, "Well, if
I don't believe in myself,
"no-one's going to believe in me."
And my take in that
insight is simply this.
No-one's going to believe
in your lofty vision,
no-one is going to embrace in
a role in your mighty mission,
if you don't viscerally believe in it.
I mean, no-one's going to believe in you,
unless you believe in you.
And Kanye, in many ways, is
a disrupter in his field.
And Kanye, in many ways,
is playing at mastery,
in terms of his craft.
But that's coming from this
incredible self-belief.
And yes, I understand, some
people will say he's arrogant,
and I, in no way, am encouraging anyone
to be arrogant, or vain.
But the larger point,
for you and I, is people
on the rise to mastery, and creating lives
that are legendary, is to
really dial in on that insight.
Which is, you know what?
We really do have to have the confidence
to believe in ourself, because
a lot of times, a leader,
a lot of times, a business
builder, a lot of times,
a craftsperson, we will
be in the wilderness,
we will have an idea for
a business or a product,
where the rest of the world
says, "That's impossible."
And we have to be coming
from a place from within,
where our I can is
larger than our I can't.
You absolutely must do the
interior work required,
where you have these fiery
levels of confidence,
where when the world is
saying, "You know what?
"I dismiss your vision,"
or "That is impossible."
You have to be that lone voice
who goes, "No, you know what?
"It is possible, and just watch me do it."
May have read by book, The
Monk Who Sold His Ferrari.
Sometimes I speak about
Ferraris, because I don't
have a Ferrari, but I love
the way that Ferrari rolls.
And here's what I mean by that.
A Ferrari is, in many ways,
mobile art on four tires.
A Ferrari, in so many
ways, is a distillation
of Enzo Ferrari's philosophy on mastery.
A Ferrari, in so many ways,
is a reminder to you and me
about what world-class stands for.
And what I really want to
dial into today is this.
Did you know that every year,
Ferrari only produces 7,000 Ferraris?
And the point of wisdom,
or the powerful idea,
I want you to really think
about, and deconstruct
in your journal tonight
after this mastery session,
is why go really wide, when
you can be singularily deep?
I'm going to repeat that again.
But a great company,
and a great performer,
goes really really deep
on one or two things,
and that's how you rise to iconic.
We live in a world, I call it
the cult of superficiality;
addicted to distraction,
afflicted by interruption.
So we take the trinity of
our performance assets:
our mental focus, our physical
energy, and our willpower.
Those are the three primary assets
of a world-class producer.
And we defuse them, we disperse them,
around thousands of projects,
lots of little things.
And yet, I think of the
7,000 Ferrari philosophy.
They are world-class, and, in terms
of producing iconic automobiles, vehicles.
But they don't want to be--
they don't appeal to everyone.
They don't produce hundreds
of thousands of vehicles.
They want to do a few products,
they want to bring out
a few things, but do
them really really well.
And that's really the craftsmen's mindset.
That's how craftsmen
think, or crafstwomen.
It's do a few things, but
do them really really well.
You are an artist.
My invitation to you,
is to produce poetry,
in terms of your work, that
the world reveals as mastery.
And that is really all about
bringing rigor to your game.
It's not about doing a lot of things,
it's about doing one thing well.
Because the secret of
genius is not complexity,
the secret of genius is simplicity.
You look at any genius
entrepreneur, you look at
any genius producer, you
look at any genius athlete,
they're not doing five sports,
they're doing one sport incredibly well,
and then putting in the training time
to be monomaniacally focused, so that they
can become otherwordly
brilliant at their one thing.
And I guess what I'm suggesting
to you, ultimately, is this.
Think about the 7,000 Ferraris philosophy.
And if you are a business
builder, let's say you're
a startup entrepreneur, let's say you're
a Fortune 500 manager, let's say you're
a professional athlete, because a lot
of professional athletes are watching
these mastery sessions.
Let's say you are a mother,
a father, a Yoga teacher,
or a chef.
What are the few things
that you could actually do
in your work, so that you
take all of your mental focus,
your physical energy, and
the willpower that you
wake up with every single morning,
and you really monomaniacally
focus those trinity
of performance assets on the few things,
the few projects, that,
when consistently iterated
and improved, every day,
over time, will allow you
to reach a place where the
world calls you world-class.
And if you can not only get this idea
on the 7,000 Ferraris
philosophy, but apply it
so it becomes a way of being,
you really will own your game.
When I was growing up,
my dad took out the poem,
and he translated it from
Sanskrit into English.
And it was a poem from the
Bengali poet Rabindranath Tagore.
And allow me to share it with you.
It simply said, "Spring has
passed, summer has gone,
"and winter is here."
"And the song I meant
to sing remains unsung,
"for I have spent my days stringing,
"and unstringing my instrument."
And my brother and I used
to look at it every morning
before we'd go off to school, but I
never really understood it.
And so when I got a little
older, I said, "Dad,
"you know that poem you had
on our refrigerator door?
"What was it all about?"
And my dad looked at me, he
said, "Robin, that was a poem
"written by a man who's
heart was filled with regret
"over a life half lived."
He said, "Robin, that was
a poem written by a man
"who postponed his life.
"He always wanted to do something special,
"he always wanted to do important work,
"he always wanted to
be loving in the world,
"he always wanted to be creative,
"he always wanted to see the world,
"but he got busy being busy."
Are you being busy being busy?
Have you lost that connection
to the life you wanted to live
when you were a little kid?
Are you so busy stringing your instrument,
that the song that your
life was meant to sing
has died, or is dormant within you?
And my challenge to you is simply this.
To do whatever it takes,
before you sleep tonight,
to reconnect with the best within you,
that you may have lost.
Because one of the things
I've noticed is this.
There are too many amongst
us, walking the planet today,
who are sort of in a waking sleep.
They have lost a sense
of who they truly are.
And your life'll never work
if there's a huge space
between who you truly are, and the person
you know you're meant to be.
Your life'll never be flooded
with energy, creativity,
productivity, and happiness,
if there is a large space
between your life right
now, and your unlived life.
And my request and encouragement,
and challenge to you,
is truly that you make
things happen, so that
the person you are, starting
tomorrow, is more of who
you know you truly are.
It makes me think of George Bernard Shaw.
He was asked on his
deathbed, what would you do
if you could live your life over again?
And he replied, after a long pause,
"I wish I could become the
person I know I was meant to be."
And I suggest to you, it's
never too late for you
to become the person
you've always wanted to be.
But don't postpone it for next year.
Don't postpone it for next month.
Start being that person, that human being,
that creative force,
that business builder,
that mother or father, that
athlete, that humanitarian,
that force of good, that you
have always wanted to be,
beginning right now.
You can be a history
maker, or you can be liked
by everyone around you.
You can't be both.
I mean, the very nature of
living your personal greatness,
and doing something otherworldly
in our world of ours,
means you're going to
have to think differently
from the majority.
You're going to have to
install the habs and routines
that most people don't do.
You're going to have to live,
talk, breathe, walk, work,
produce, create in a way that most people,
who are card-carrying members
of the cult of mediocrity,
just don't buy into.
When you look at most people
out on the world today,
and this is not judging,
this is just reporting,
but they're addicted to
entertainment, they love gossiping,
they're negative, they're
toxic, anyone who wants
to do anything great, they
want to bring them down,
they dismiss the
game-changers, and they're
just coasting through life.
And so the very nature of
you stepping up your game,
living your greatest potential,
owning your craft, dominating your field,
and living a life that's
legendary, means you're going to
have to leave the 5%, and make a decision,
to live as very few people do.
And what does that mean?
It means you're going to
be laughed at, it means
you're going to be ridiculed,
it means you're going
to be misunderstood, because
leadership is a lonely sport,
and it means you just might be hated.
And so there is great value
when people start to hate you.
Because if you look at Jay-Z, I mean I was
reading his biography, and he
said, "You know, I really knew
"that I was having influence
in the popular culture,
"when people started hating me."
If you look a lot of the great authors,
when their books go to
number one globally,
a lot of the amateurs
actually start to say,
"Oh, that's garbage, I
could put them down."
I watched a documentary
last night on Steve Aoki,
the famous EDM, electric dance music, DJ,
who is giving so much traction
in the world right now,
and he was talking about
some of the comments
that he sees in the social media.
And it was things like,
garbage, and boring,
and amateurish music, and whatever.
Even though he's so skilled,
I mean, you just watch
the documentary called
I'll Sleep When I'm Dead,
and you just see the skill.
And you can just look
at any great athlete,
and you could look at any great scientist,
you could look at any
great chef, you could look
at any great artist, you could
look at any great author,
you could look at any great
statesman, you could look
at any world-class stateswoman.
Anyone who has done something
at an exceptional level,
breeds cynics and dismissers.
So, the point is simply
this, the very nature
of doing something that very
few people are willing to do,
means that the majority will laugh at you.
Why?
Because deep inside, they
know they have the opportunity
to do something great, too.
And your example makes them feel guilty.
And all I'm suggesting to you,
with great love and respect,
is simply this.
You do have a choice.
You can listen to your haters,
you can be one of the haters,
you can join the victim
herd, you can dismiss people
who are doing great things,
or you can reach into yourself
and ask yourself this
fundamental question:
what do I want to stand for
for the rest of my life?
Do I really want to rise to mastery?
Do I want to get to the
last hour of my last day,
and know that I took every
ounce of the human potential
I was blessed with, and through easy times
and difficult times, I
brought it on, and as a result
of my values, my mindsets,
my heartset, my habits,
my routines, my disciplines,
I was-- I owned my game,
and I modeled possibility,
and I served lots of people,
and I built a great lifestyle,
and now it's the last hour
of my last day, and I'm
surrounded by my loved ones,
and even though people threw stones at me,
I took those stones, and
rather than being knocked down,
I constructed a monument
of mastery that stands
as my legacy.
And if you live like that,
you'll be one of the great ones.
Which is my greatest wish for you.
You're in a restaurant, the
server generally gives you
what you expect, or less
than what you expect.
You go into a clothing
store, it's what you expect,
or less than what you expect.
You do business with any
organization, it's generally
delivering on what you expect,
but more often, even less.
So, you have a gorgeous
opportunity to lead the field
in everything that you
do, by doing one thing.
Practicing every single
day, because it's a muscle,
the ritual of overdelivering.
Don't just give your
customers what they expect,
give them 10X more than what they expect.
Don't just give your
organization what your manager,
what your boss, what the
organization is expecting from you,
show something that is so rare
in today's economy: initiative.
Initiative.
So, you're asked to do a project,
give them five more things
than they expect.
You're asked to give a
presentation on something,
go the extra mile.
Consistently dial in the
daily habit of overdelivering
on people's expectations.
And guess what?
You become a merchant of wow.
You become indispensable
to your organization.
I wrote a book a little while ago
called The Greatness Guide,
and one of the chapters
talked about the importance
of being indispensable.
And I learnt that when
I was a young lawyer.
And I remember talking to my mentor.
And I asked my mentor,
you know the top litigator
at this firm, how come he is the icon
of the legal profession in this region?
And my mentor looked at me
and said, "Robin, because
"that person is
indispensable to this firm."
Well how do you do that?
By practicing the ritual of
overdelivering every single day
for the rest of your life.
Be yourself, everyone else is taken.
Well that really speaks to the
power of being an original.
It speaks to this concept of authenticity.
Being yourself.
I mean, we live in a world
where there has never been
so much of a seduction
to be like everyone else.
There's never been so much
influence, and hypnosis,
through the social media,
and through society,
to talk in a certain way,
to walk in a certain way,
to buy certain things,
to measure your success
by the same philosophy.
And what I'm encouraging
you to do, based on
this Oscar Wilde quote, is to be yourself.
I mean, talk your talk, walk
your walk, take the time
to reflect on your dream,
be true to your own values.
Because life's greatest
heartbreak is self-betrayal.
Make your I can more important
than your even your IQ.
Now you're saying, "Robin,
what are you talking
"about right here?"
Well a lot of people get stuck
in victimhood versus leadership,
by the seduction of saying,
"Well, I'm not smart enough.
"I'm not intelligent enough."
Well, you are intelligent enough.
What's even more important is
your mindset of possibility.
You see, if you look at the
best athletes in the world,
the best musicians in the
world, the best entrepreneurs
in the world, the best
managers in the world,
the best CEOs in the world,
the best coders in the world,
the best pizza makers in the
world, the best mums and pops,
et cetera, et cetera.
Those who get a le--
level results, are not
the most intelligent, or
naturally gifted people
in their field, but these
are the people that have
that mindset of possibility,
and it's all about I can.
And that might sound like a
bit of a platitude, you know,
having an attitude of I can,
a mindset of possibility,
a mentality of legendary.
But when you really deconstruct
it, it's really true.
The way you begin each
day, sets up the way
you live each day.
I mean, the Spartan
warriors said it so well.
Sweat more in training, bleed less in war.
And if you want to be, literally
undefeatable in business,
literally unstoppable
in life, you really want
to dial in your morning routine.
And so you want to do things
like starting the day sweating,
because that releases BDNF,
brain-derived neurotrophic factor,
that repairs brain cells from stress.
You want to sweat because
that's going to increase
your metabolic rate, which
is going to give you energy.
And we live in a world where energy
is even more valuable than intelligence.
You want to, in your morning
routine, take the time
to write in a journal, so
you actually can detect
your values, where you connect
with your goals each day,
get to know yourself even
more, because awareness
is the beginning of transformation.
And you want to get your
morning routine right,
so you take some time at the
front-end of your day to learn,
because as you learn more, you know you're
going to achieve more.
And as you understand better,
you can achieve larger.
For the past number of years,
I've been reading obituaries.
And you might say, "Robin,
that's negative," and I
don't think it's negative, I
think it's really positive.
Because I think few things are
as powerful to wake you up,
to remind you about what's most important,
to fuel your energy, to
get you into the game,
so you let go of your fears,
and you do what you need to do
to get big things done,
than connecting to your own mortality.
When you realize that every
single day could be your last,
or when you appreciate that,
no matter how long you live,
life is a short ride, you just
sort of let go of the fears,
and you let go of the
limits, and you live full-on,
and you seize opportunities,
and you have real conversations
with real people, and you
sort of wear your heart
on your sleeve, and you
bring on the fullness
of your authenticity, and
you do whatever it takes
to get your loftiest dreams to get done.
And so I read these obituaries.
And it reminds me about
what life is all about.
And relatively recently, I've
started walking in cemeteries.
I was in Mauritius a little while ago.
It's a-- I don't know if
you've been to Mauritius,
but it's this paradise on Earth.
It's this tiny island, about four hours
off the coast of Cape Town.
And I've been to Mauritius
a number of times.
I was there to give a
big leadership event,
I talked about leading without
a title, so it was filled
with iconic CEOs, and people
running big industries,
and big companies, and
entrepreneurs, and startup people,
and it was really wonderful.
But I also took about a week
and a half, just to refuel,
and to work on my new
book, and to reconnect
with my values, and to set
myself up for the coming months.
And one of the things I did,
was I went for a long walk.
I love walking, I find
interesting-- like I find
a lot of the most creative people,
the most productive people in the planet,
they all have one thing in
common, they have the routine
of walking on a regular basis.
And so, I love walking.
I've walked in nature for many many years.
And so here I am in Mauritius,
and I just started walking.
And I was actually
listening to an interview
of Charlie Rose and Steve Martin,
and it was done in New York,
in front of an audience
of a few thousand people, and it was about
an hour and a half long.
And Steve Martin was
talking about his career,
and Charlie Rose is one
of the great interviewers
of our time, so he was asking
about how he became so good
at what he did, and his
life, and his love of art,
and stand-up comedy, and acting.
I mean, he-- Steve Martin
became an actor after
a stand-up comedian, et cetera.
And so I'm walking, and the
Sun is setting, and I'm walking
along the Indian Ocean, and
I'm looking at the flowers.
And I get to this little village.
And it's this really...
this little village
with a lot of character.
And as I'm walking along
the edge of the village,
still close to the
seaside, I spot a cemetery.
And I've learned to follow my instincts
more than ever before, because instinct
is more powerful than reason,
and life will lead you
to an interesting place,
if you stay with the flow.
And so, I walked towards
this cemetery, and I walked
into this cemetery.
And I started walking
through the cemetery,
very respectfully and carefully.
But it was interesting
to me, because a lot
of the tombstones were
just made out of wood.
And (clears throat)
somewhat sadly, some of
the wooden crosses, were
actually really really small.
And you could tell that the
gravesites were of kids.
And as I walked through the
cemetery, I saw these crosses,
and I saw some tombstones,
some looked very old,
a few graves looked fresh.
And it reminded me, really,
about the shortness of life.
I mean Marcus Aurelius has
written one of my favorite books,
the Meditations of Marcus
Aurelius, and actually
he didn't write it.
Marcus Aurelius was a
Roman Emperor, and during
a long military campaign,
in his journal, he wrote
his thoughts and his
philosophies, and someone
found those diaries, those
journals, and made them
into this book, called the
Meditations of Marcus Aurelius.
And he does talk about
the shortness of life,
and so does Epictetus, and a lot
of the great Stoic philosophers.
And being in this cemetery,
and walking through it
with great delicacy, it
reminded me how short life is.
And it reminded me we all
have hopes and dreams,
and we never know when those
dreams are going to get dashed.
And we never know when
our last day will unfold.
Some people will wake up
tomorrow morning, they'll get
in their car, they'll
take a shower or they'll
have their coffee, they'll say
goodbye to their loved ones,
and that will be the last
day that their loved ones
will ever see them.
Some people on the planet
the day after tomorrow,
will go into their doctor's
office to get the result
of a routine checkup,
and the doctor will say,
"Sit down, I've got
some sad news for you,"
and they'll be diagnosed
with maybe some kind
of a terminal illness.
I mean, accidents, illness,
tragedy, catastrophe,
is also a reality of humanity.
And so, what I'm suggesting
to you is, do whatever
it takes to be in the
moment, and to stay positive,
and to stay on your game,
and to optimize your craft,
and to spend time with your loved ones,
and to take care of your
fitness, and to learn
something new every day, and
to enjoy the beauty of sunsets
and star-filled nights,
and at the same time,
as much as possible, please,
do not lose perspective.
Stay connected to your mortality.
Steve Jobs in that famous Stanford speech,
said it really well, "You are naked,
"you have nothing to lose."
And he learnt that when he
connected to his cancer.
And so, maybe you will install
a ritual, once a month,
on the way home from work, you
will pull over to a cemetery,
and you'll spend five
minutes, even, in meditation,
looking at the tombstones,
looking at the crosses,
studying the graves, or
whatever your tradition is,
in whatever nation you're from,
because not every tradition,
I know, has the gravesites.
Sometimes it's the funeral
pyre, which really...
reminds me that life is really short,
and you never know when your
last day is going to be.
And so just build some kind
of a routine to remind you
on the shortness of life.
So that you tell the people you love
how you feel about them,
so you write the letters
that need to be written,
and I know people don't
write letters, but writing
a letter to someone
you need to express forgiveness
to, or gratitude to,
is really powerful.
Pursue the projects that will allow you to
be the legend of your industry.
Chase the passions that fuel your joy.
And live every day as if it was your last,
because we never know when
our last day will show up.
- Thank you guys so much for watching.
I made this video because
Jemal M asked me to.
If there's someone
you'd like me to profile
in their Future Top 10,
please check out the link
down in the description below,
and you can cast your vote
on who we should do next.
I also want to give a
quick shoutout to Jude.
Jude, thank you so much
for pickin' up a copy
of my book, Your One Word, and
taking that awesome picture,
and sharing it with me.
I really really appreciate the support,
and I hope you enjoyed the read.
Thank you guys again for watching.
I believe in you.
I hope you continue to
believe in yourself,
and whatever your one word is, much love.
I'll see you soon.
(swooshing)
(booming)
- Run your own race.
And that's really the
first lesson I learned from
one of my mentors.
Run your own race.
Stay in your own lane.
You have no competition, if
you are in your own division.
And what I mean by that is simply this.
It's so easy to get swept off your game,
swept off your vision,
swept off your values,
swept off your focus, when
you're measuring your success,
and your performance,
by your so-called peers
in your industry, or your
competition within your craft.
And that first lesson was
so profound, he simply said,
"Run your own race."
You know?
Come up with your ambition,
come up with your vision,
and have this singular focus,
and the character discipline,
to say I'm just going
to put these blinders on
and stay true to myself,
true to my values,
true to my vision.
So I've been living my life, recently,
under one compelling
standard, and simply this.
Be only with people, do
only the work, and be only
in the spaces and
places, that fuel my joy.
I think life is too short to be depleted.
And so I've spent a lot
of my life helping people
rise to iconic as
producers, and performers,
and creatives, and
entrepreneurs, and leaders.
And so what I wanted to do
in this mastery session,
is really share with you
some of the things I do
in my own life to fuel
my joy, fuel my energy,
fuel my creativity.
And what I'm really speaking
of here, is adventure.
So if you talk to any good neurobiologist,
they will tell you that
the brain craves novelty.
The way we are hard-wired,
is to pursue joy,
to pursue novelty, to pursue newness.
And that's why, so often,
we start something,
but we really don't finish it.
We're always looking
for that one new thing,
that will fuel our joy, fuel our ideation,
fuel our creativity.
It's almost like, we've got
this inner child within us,
constantly longing to
see the light of day.
And you know adults are nothing more
than deteriorated children,
you never want to lose
that connection with that
festive, fiery, sparkling,
creative, playful inner child.
I mean, the more you can
connect with that inner child,
the more you're going to find
your productivity growing
exponentially, your creativity
firing up, and basically
you're just going out
into your industry,
and out into the world,
and radiating positivity.
So, what are some of the things
that I do do fuel my joy,
and to keep that sense of adventure alive,
so I don't lose the sparkle in my eye?
Traveling.
I just love being on airplanes.
Fundamentally, I am a nomad.
So, I love being in Rome
and eating the pasta,
and experiencing the fresh
mozzarella di bufala,
or the burrata, watching
the way the light falls
over the architecture.
I just love Rome so much.
I love getting up in the morning,
while the Romans are asleep,
and running up to Monti,
and then past the Colosseum,
and then past Trevi Fountain.
I mean, that is one of the
greatest runs, I think,
on the planet, at least for me.
I love going to Mauritius.
Why do I love Mauritius?
It's this island paradise,
where no-one can find me,
and I can immerse myself in
creativity, and I can refuel.
You talk about adventure,
going to Mauritius
and swimming with the
dolphins, is one of the things
you need to do on your before
I die list, before you die.
I just love places like Stockholm.
I love Latin America.
I love the Middle East.
I adore Europe.
I love London.
I love Switzerland, because I love to ski.
I love going to India.
I love going to Southeast Asia.
I love traveling the planet.
Because here's the thing,
I don't think there is
a better education known to
humankind, than traveling.
Michelangelo is really a great story
on willpower, and self-control.
He was beaten severely
when he was a young kid
by his father.
His father wanted him to be-- to pursue
a more noble profession, a
more lucrative profession.
And Michelangelo wanted to be a sculptor.
And his father beat him,
and his father tried to s--
to get him off course.
And Michelangelo said, "No,
I want to be a sculptor."
And finally, through his
grit and perseverance,
and unrelenting-ness,
Michelangelo's father said,
"You know what, okay fine.
"You're 14 years old,
I'm going to allow you
"to go to apprentice
with a Florentine master,
"and he will help you become a sculptor."
And Michelangelo moved to
Florence, and he started to study,
and he started to practice.
And again, this is a
story of self-discipline,
and world-class willpower.
And through his mastery,
and through his practice,
and through his suffering,
and through his persistence,
and through his focus, all
of these great lost traits,
that are no longer
celebrated in this world
where all-too-often, people
are card-carrying members
of the cult of mediocrity.
Through this practice,
through this devotion,
he became well-known.
He became known far and wide.
He created that-- the
beautiful sculpture, David.
If you go to Museum of
Accademia in Florence,
you will see David.
You will see some of
his other masterpieces.
And, part of that whole
region started to honor
the way that Michelangelo
was appearing and performing
as a sculptor.
Because of his mastery, a
lot of the other artists,
like Raphael, and the
Renaissance painters,
became-- they became jealous.
And so they devised a very
elaborate and interesting plan
to discredit and to ridicule Michelangelo.
And, Michelangelo's
peers went to the Pope,
who was Julius II.
And they said to the Pope,
"Why don't you get Michelangelo
"to paint the Sistine Chapel?"
And the Pope said, "Sounds good."
And so the Pope went over
the Michelangelo, and said,
"I want you to restore
the greatness of Rome.
"And the greatness of Rome
is now on your shoulders,
"because I want you to
paint the Sistine Chapel.
"And I want you to make it a masterpiece
"that holds the world in
awe when they see it."
And Michelangelo replied
to the Pope, he said,
"You know, I'm not a painter,
and I've never painted,
"I am a sculptor."
But Julius II was very persistent,
and eventually Michelangelo said,
"Fine, I'm going to agree."
And over four years, four
hard years, four of the years
that took incredible
self-control, incredible grit,
we're going to talk about
grit in this webinar,
incredible focus, incredible discipline.
Michelangelo created the Sistine Chapel.
Now, let's put this into perspective.
I mean, Michelangelo had
never painted fresco before,
Michelangelo had to paint
something on the ceiling
of the Sistine Chapel that
people standing many feet below
could look up at and
see with great detail.
Michelangelo dealt with
the fact that the painting
on the Sistine Chapel was
moldy, there were paint issues.
He had to deal with the fact
that the Pope was very ill,
and he thought he might not get paid.
He actually developed this
incredible, elaborate system
of scaffolding, which
allowed him to paint--
to paint backwards, for four
years, on the Sistine Chapel,
and he damaged his back in the process.
But he did it for the art,
he did it for the discipline,
he did it for what it made of him,
he did it for his commitment,
because the great artists,
and the great performers
are much less about ego,
and applause, and money,
and they do their work
for what it makes of them as human beings.
And after four years,
Michelangelo's eyesight
was so damaged from looking at the images
on the Sistine Chapel, that he
suffered permanent eye damage.
But like I said, once he was finished,
the world was awestruck
at what he created.
And now, 20 million people
a year go to the Vatican,
and they do experience this
breath-taking work of artistry,
and human ingenuity,
constructed by an ordinary man,
who exercised world-class
willpower, named Michelangelo.
And so, ladies and gentlemen,
I guess what I'm suggesting
to you, is one of fundamental points.
The myth of the talented genius,
the myth of the gifted
genius, is nothing more
than a lie society has told you.
I don't know if I expressed that clearly,
but what I'm trying to suggest to you is,
the world says, the
Michelangelos, and the Beckhams,
and the Jay-Zs, and the...
the great entrepreneurs, the Carlos Slims,
the Warren Buffetts, the
Jack Dorseys, you know
the founder of Twitter, the Jeff Bezoses,
the founder of Amazon, the
Mozarts, and the Picassos,
and the Bachs.
Society teaches us, and
trains us, that these people
are somehow born with special talents.
And what I'm here to remind
you, with deep respect
for all 25,000, or 24,922
of you on this webinar
from around the world, is that is a lie
that society has sold
us, to keep us small.
And if you look at the
science, and science coming out
right now is indisputable, we're going to
get into that science.
But what science says, is
genius is much less about--
about your genetics, and much more about
your self-control, and your discipline.
Genius is much less about natural talent,
and much more about practice,
persistence, focus, grit,
dealing with suffering,
dealing with failure,
dealing with laughter,
while the rest of the world
thinks you should stop,
genius is much more
about continuing, practice,
developing your craft.
(swooshing)